c'est un voyage dont il rêvait depuis
toujours et qui pose un jalon important
tu as passé quelques minutes dans
l'espace 17 ans après la création de sa
compagnie virgin galactic
le milliardaire s'est envolé vers 10h40
depuis la base de ce passeport au
nouveau mexique accompagné de trois
autres passagers et de deux pilotes à
quelques kilomètres de haut le vaisseau
s'est détachée de son avion porteur et a
poursuivi son ascension vers l'espace
avant de descendre les passagers ont pu
flotter en apesanteur et admirer la
terre pendant quelques instants
mais l'objectif de richard branson avec
ce vol d'essai tester et évaluer
l'expérience de ses futurs clients
virgin galactic vis 2022 pour le début
de ces vols commerciaux
mais avec les prix qui varient entre 250
et 500 mille dollars le billet laventure
ne s'adressera qu'aux plus privilégiés
néanmoins pour la compagnie le tourisme
spatial tourner une page de son histoire
si deux autres milliardaires dans la
course au tourisme spatial
jeff bezos ceo elon musk qui ont lancé
eux aussi leur propre société spatiale
l'homme le plus riche de la planète doit
s'envoler dans neuf jours
alors que la fusée del bosque décollera
en septembre ici et me lemieux radio
canada montréal